[Music]
you remember like in
january and february when we were like
the worst thing we were worried about
was fires in australia
and uh then all of a sudden the fires in
australia were bad
and covid was bad and then tornadoes
came
and then fires out west and then kovit
was bad and then
then politicians are morons and then
we shut the economy down and then
politicians are morons
and then there was fires out west and
then you remember this year as a
dumpster fire
it is for real 2020 i am going to
celebrate you leaving
i'm having one hellacious new year's eve
party
but remember what happened to the
stock market in march april
when the economic suppression
was put in place by your politicians
stock market dove you all remember
you remember ramsey personalities did
478 media hits
in 32 days
90 of our media hits were chris hogan me
rachel cruz whoever looking at the
camera going
don't sell your freaking retirement
it'll come back
it's down temporarily it'll come back
the only person that gets hard on a
roller coaster
is those that jump off in the middle of
the ride ride it baby
it'll be back and uh
we actually pulled back up it broke our
new record a few weeks ago the stock
market did
um meaning that it recovered completely
it was a record in january
and then it came back in august and set
another record
and so it took like i think we counted
up i think it was 57 days for it to
fully recover
did you hear any news media doing a
story
the american economy is so robust that
it completely recovered from the worst
economic false shutdown in the history
of the world
in 57 days did you hear that as a
headline
nope you didn't
did you see some headlines when it was
diving that you were going to die and
the world was coming to an end
and you should tune in tonight because
there's also going to be a tornado
did you see those headlines if it bleeds
it leads and you people get addicted to
fear
fear porn and you're sucked in
by fox and cnn in your local news
and you sit with your kneecap pressed to
the edge of your television
knowing that your world is coming to an
end
and never once do they tell you the
truth
57 days later he was 57 might have been
56 but somewhere right in there
stock market completely recovered so
with with this environment that you and
i live in
you have to put some people in your
corner with your investments
that will look at you very clear-eyed
and say don't make decisions when you're
freaked
don't make decisions when you're drunk
these are two dumb times to make big
decisions put the wine down
and sit down no you're not cashing in
your retirement i'll choke you
because people cashed in at exactly the
bottom didn't they how many of us know
somebody cashing in at the bottom
i have friends and they're freaking
friends of dave ramsey who cashed it in
at the bottom and i couldn't stop them
from doing it
they were freaked out and they ran out
into the interstate and got run over by
an 18-wheeler
you become financial roadkill
because you're panicked like a deer
you ever see these squirrels squirrel
runs out in the road can't decide which
way to go bumble
you make squirrel decisions when you
freak out because you get stuck you get
paralyzed by fear
and you do stupid butt stuff and you
need somebody in your corner
so the dow jones industrial average is
approximately twenty seven thousand
dollars as i broadcast this particular
episode
twenty seven thousand dollars twenty
twenty seven thousand
and i'm the same guy in 2008 when it
went from 13 000 to 6400
that told you not to cash out then
it went in half that time this time it
didn't go in half it went from about
28 down to about 19 and then came back
in 56 or 57 days
now i understand it's scary
but that doesn't mean you step on the
gas and let go of the wheel
you just you have to have i mean
if you hit ice driving down the road at
60 miles an hour
what do you do slam on the brakes no
this is how you total your car fool
you let off of everything and just let
it roll through baby
and hold the wheel and hopefully course
correct a little bit but
into the steer into the slide but i mean
you don't step on the brakes and you
don't step on the gas
and there's some common sense aspect of
this whole thing did you sell your house
when houses went down in value
no because you knew houses would come
back same thing here
same thing here so nobody gets hurt on a
roller coaster except those that jump
off in the middle
i wish i had told you something
different
one single time so people could say i
was inconsistent
and they would be right but they're
wrong i've told you the exact
same thing about investing for 30
years and by the way it's what i
personally do with investing my only
temptation is and i don't do it
but my only temptation is when the stock
market goes down like it is to invest
more and i don't even do that because i
don't believe in market timing i just
invest and invest and invest and invest
and invest
and i want to be consistent with who i
say that i am and i don't want to
tell you to do something that i don't do
with investing
so a hundred percent of the things that
i teach you to do with investing
i personally do and uh
i just got some more zeros on it but
that's it
it's it's just you know so i don't even
invest when i'm tempted to but i mean
think about it
think about this okay if the stock
market recovered 30 something percent
in 57 days and you had put in a million
dollars
what would that have turned into
see that's tempting that right there is
some tempting numbers
and i knew that was coming i didn't know
it's gonna be 57 days or 157 days but i
knew it's coming back and
i'm thinking dad come it
but i i you know i don't i don't
violate the principles that i live by
for greed or for fear because when you
do that's when you get stepped on
that's how it works so get with a smart
vester pro get some people in your
corner that calm your butt
down so you don't freak out in these
weird times that we
always are going to have
after covid there will be something else
after 2008 there will be something else
after 911 there will be something else
after black monday 1987 there will be
something else
there's always something else